[Musique]
par la fenêtre de sa maison Anatolie a
vu les Russes venir d'accord
Anatolie est arrêté et torturé pendant
24 jours
une fois ces tortionnaire le force à
sauter pendant 1h30
Anatolie est libérée début septembre
juste avant que les forces sucréniennes
n'entre dans balaglia si les Russes
étaient restées ils pensent que cela
aurait été pire
dans le collimateur des forces russes
des patriotes Ukrainiens comme Anatolie
ex membre du conseil municipal il a
désormais repris son travail au marché
un semblant de retour à la vie normale
au marché de balakia les clients se
pressent de nouveau dans les allées
et les ouvriers s'activent là où les
bonbons fait des dégâts
le commissariat de police ou les Russes
avaient installé une chambre de torture
a repris ses fonctions
cet homme qui se nomme Anatolie lui
aussi est venu déposer une demande de
nouveaux passeports
si Anatolie doit renouveler son
passeport c'est parce que les Russes le
lion ont pris quand ils l'ont détenu ici
pendant 100 jours
[Musique]
alors qu'un atelier et son épouse s'en
vont cette passante s'arrête pour nous
dire que son fils un juge à lui aussi
était torturé dans ce poste de police
il refuse et on le relâche mais il est
arrêté de nouveau à de reprise lui aussi
et menaçait d'exécution pour avoir
poursuivi des séparatistes prorus
mais le tribunal au travail son fils
n'est pas prêt de se remettre à
fonctionner
[Musique]
des détails sur ces arrestations dont
nous a parlé sa mère
des histoires comme celle-ci et bien
d'autres se font entendre dans toutes
les localités reprises aux Russes par
l'armée ukrainienne